rats are running amok but generally here
in India they're not reviled the way
they can be in the United States in fact
too many in India rats are sacred 80% of
the Indian population is Hindus and in
the Hindu religion rats are believed to
be companions of the god Ganesh rats are
admired and revered for their cunning
and adaptability and it goes against the
religion of many Indians to kill them
hence how the rats reproduce is such a
ferocious rate they can't be contained
stopped or even slowed down let's do the
math each mother rat can have up to 12
babies in a litter she can have a litter
a month a hundred and forty-four babies
a year her babies will start having
babies two months after they're born and
those babies will start having babies
two months after that
one couple just one can produce 15,000
descendants in a year so where are all
these rats going to live in burrows that
have to be dug out and expanded and
remodeled constantly which is what helps
keep the rats teeth from growing too
long of course with all these tunnels
comes the accidental meeting of two
alpha males both rats survive the
scuffle which might mean another 30,000
rats by next year holy Road